في الأيام القليلة الماضية هنا في أوكرانيا ،
وقع أعنف قتال على
الجبهة الشرقية لهذا الصراع
حتى أن المصادر الأوكرانية والروسية
تقول إن اللواء الآلي الروسي الذي
يحاول الدفع عبر بلدة
volidar شهد خسائر كبيرة وأنت
ترى هذا الفيديو الدرامي لكونك
يتم دفعها للخلف مع تكبد ضحايا
من ضربات الطائرات بدون طيار والمدفعية الآن ،
تقول المخابرات الدفاعية للمملكة المتحدة إن هذه هي أسوأ فترة
خسائر للروس منذ
بداية هذه الحرب التي يصعب
تكديسها ، لكنها بالتأكيد كانت
فترة شديدة للغاية من  تقاتل هناك
القوات الروسية لديها القوات ،
وفي الواقع ، حقق المقاولون العسكريون الخاصون
نجاحًا أكبر إلى حد ما في
شمال تلك المدينة في منطقة باكموت ،
لكنك لا ترى مكاسب كبيرة
من الأراضي في هذه الفترة من
حرب الاستنزاف هنا في هذا
الصراع في كييف والمناطق المحيطة
بالعاصمة يقولون إنهم
تمكنوا من إبقاء الأضواء مضاءة طوال
اليوم وهو
إنجاز مهم يقول وزير الطاقة
بسبب تلك الهجمات الأخيرة
بالصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار التي قام بها الروس أن
العديد منهم  تمكن الأوكرانيون
من إسقاطه ، وقال أيضًا إن
أعمال الإصلاح تمكنهم من إبقاء
الأضواء على الأمر مهمًا لأن
روسيا كانت تتطلع إلى كسر روح
المدنيين الأوكرانيين من خلال استهداف
البنية التحتية لشيء لم
يتمكنوا من تحقيقه ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن إن
كيث
أجنبي